[Musique]
après avoir traversé 9 mois de guerre
les Ukrainiens se préparent maintenant à
affronter l'hiver qui s'installe malgré
les reculs de l'armée russe
l'intensification des bombardements sur
les réseaux électriques fait craindre
des mois sans couronnes ni chauffage la
Canadienne Denise Brown œuvre depuis 25
ans dans des zones de conflits comme la
République centrafricaine l'Afghanistan
ou l'Irak c'est elle qui coordonne les
programmes d'aide des Nations Unies en
Ukraine je la retrouve aujourd'hui à
Kiev madame brand bon dimanche merci
d'être avec nous merci beaucoup après 9
mois de guerre en Ukraine dites moi
comment est la situation sur le terrain
la situation est complètement je dirais
bouleversant je passe beaucoup de temps
dans le dans les zones qui sont touchées
par la guerre le niveau de la
destruction des bâtiments des
infrastructures des écoles des maisons
et complètement choquant le déplacement
de la population plus de 6 millions de
personnes qui sont pas chez eux et 8
millions qui ont quitté le pays parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas en sécurité à cause
de la guerre et le niveau de besoin
humanitaire c'est simplement immense
c'est 18 millions de personnes parlons
de ses besoins justement quels sont les
besoins les plus pressants d'après vous
j'étais à personne lundi 3 jours après
l'arrivée des militaires ukrainienne
c'est des choses de base des choses de
tous les jours il y avait pas de
électricité donc il y avait pas d'eau
dans toute la ville les chaînes
d'approvisionnement des vives a été
complètement interrompue même chose pour
les médicaments j'ai eu des écoles
d'étude donc la vie quotidienne est
complètement détruite combien
d'ukrainien à l'heure actuelle ont
besoin de votre il y a des Ukrainiens
qui s'en sortent mieux d'autres je
présume combien du crayon besoin d'être
immédiate d'aide immédiatement selon nos
analyses il y a 18 millions de
ukrainiennes qui sont dans le pays
actuellement je parle même pas des réf
qui sont à l'extérieur qui ont besoin
d'une aide pour pour le quotidien pour
les vivre pour l'eau pour un foyer pour
les vêtements et donc c'est c'est voilà
c'est 40% de la population parler de
besoins de base de dos d'électricité
concrètement bon vous êtes sur le
terrain combien d'agences de l'ONU sur
le terrain qu'est-ce que vous faites
exactement
mais on est plus de ça ONG national et
international et on fait vraiment
énormément dans des dans des zones
touchées directement par par la guerre
et donc c'est c'est tout si vous n'êtes
plus dans votre maison parce que la
maison a été détruite vous n'êtes plus
dans votre maison parce que le guerre
est en cours vous laissez tout derrière
votre emploi votre l'école et vos
enfants votre maison vos vêtements vous
avez besoin de tout donc actuellement on
occupe de tout ça on arrive à toucher 13
millions de personnes c'est assez
difficile il y a les risques des mines
il y a des attaques des missiles
pratiquement tous les jours y compris
aussi à Kiev donc c'est un travail très
compliqué mais on arrive quand même à
toucher la population
parlez-moi madame brand l'arrivée de
l'hiver on voyait des images cette
semaine
une petite couche de neige là à Kiev un
peu partout en Ukraine l'hiver commence
qu'est-ce que ça change comme dynamique
pour vous pour les besoins sur le
terrain ça change beaucoup de choses
depuis mon arrivée la fin du mois de
juillet on a déjà commencé les
préparations pour l'hiver aider la
population dans les gens de plus
touchées retaper les maisons s'assurer
qu'il y a des générateurs pour les
hôpitaux pour que ça fonctionne
s'assurer que les personnes qui sont
déplacées qui vivent dans des centres
sont dans des conditions ou ils sont en
dignité ils sont en sécurité toutes ces
préparations sont en cours mais c'est
compliqué par le perte de de l'énergie
dont le président de la ski on parle
ouvertement et donc les 10 millions de
personnes qui estiment non plus d'accès
ni à l'électricité ni au chauffage donc
nos préparations pour les populations
touchées par la guerre sont en cours
mais il y a aussi un crise d'énergie
très importante qui arrive votre défi
principal dans ce contexte là de quoi
vous avez besoin vous pour aider ces
gens-là on a l'argent pour aider la
population une des très grosses
difficultés que nous avons actuellement
c'est la présence des mines et donc en
allant à personne
lundi on a vu clairement des mortiers au
bord de la route donc nous envoyons nos
collègues dans des zones quand même à
haute risques et donc l'argent est là le
matériel sont plus ou moins disponibles
mais c'est cet aspect de risque est très
très important et il faut qu'on le gère
est-ce que c'est dangereux pour vous de
travailler sur le terrain mais c'est
dangereux pour nous comme c'est
dangereux pour la population où il y a
comme je dis tout à l'heure il y a des
attaques avec des missiles pratiquement
tous les jours je ne suis pas dans une
compon de Nations Unies je vis comme
tout le monde mon petit appartement à
mon bureau on est aussi exposé on est
tous exposés en fait qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez pour l'Ukraine pour la suite
des choses comment comment vous
envisagez le reste les prochains mois
moi je souhaite que pour les mois qui
viennent qui qui s'annonce très froid
quand vous avez dit à déjà la neige à
Kiev qu'on arrive ensemble à passer chez
moi qui vont être longues
fois et très compliqué j'espère qu'on va
arriver à surmonter ces défis
Denis Brown chef de l'ONU à Kiev en
Ukraine merci infiniment d'avoir été des
nôtres merci à vous merci